hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
August 11 and I'd like to start off this
video by apologizing to those of you who
were not happy we referred to the Elder
Scrolls 6al Skyrim to in yesterday's
video title we do like to save on
character but I promise not to hurt you
like that again there's a good chance
you or someone you know is playing
everybody's gone to the rapture if
that's the case there's an even better
chance that that person has complained
about moving so freaking slowly the ps4
exclusive grabbed itself a 9 out of 10
from our gamespot review but even so
that hasn't put a pin in the complaints
of many critics saying the game's
movement is agonizingly slow and that
this really hurts the game when you do
need to do a bit of backtracking well it
turns out that the game has had a secret
sprint button all along creative
director Dan Pinchbeck revealed in a
blog post that holding down art too lets
you gradually move faster and the game
doesn't tell you about it because the
feature was a very late addition
initially sprinting was an automatic
feature which kicked in after you've
walked for a few seconds but they
decided to make this a player decision
days before release and didn't have time
to include the information in the actual
game end of PSA you've probably heard by
now that Peter Dinklage's voice is being
replaced by nolan north as the role of
your Guardians ghost in destiny today we
found that a little more about wine
Bungie told game informer that the role
was recast in part due to what they
refer to as Hollywood nonsense executive
producer Mark noseworthy said Dinklage
was awesome to work with on destiny one
so we just needed to work with someone
who is more available Nolan he's a pro
this is his thing we can call him up and
say hey next week can we do this thing
and he's available Noseworthy had
nothing but good things to say about
Dinklage otherwise according to rock
star n 2k games parent company take to
mafia 3 and GTA 5 are not the same
aim not even close you know in case you
were worried during an earnings call
take to CEO Strauss Zelnick was asked if
mopping a3 should be thought of as a
rock star style open-world game darling
called mafia 3 a completely different
experience adding I wouldn't compare it
to anything else out there as for GTA
tzelek said we don't use any other game
in the same sentence as grand theft auto
it is the industry standard bearer it's
not up for comparison Zelnick added that
the company's two main labels rock star
and 2k do not share technology because
they don't believe it's a good way to
get the best out of their developers
mafia 3 is expected to land sometime
after April next year do you think
there's a big difference between the
Mafia and GTA franchises let me know
your thoughts down in that comment
section you can add a game spa we've got
stories on xbox one backwards
compatibility and how you can vote on PS
Plus games that is everything that I
want to tell you about today as always
let me know what mattered to you and I
will care to same time tomorrow